-Our first guest tonight
is a best-selling author
and the Emmy-winning host
of "The Rachel Maddow Show,"
which airs weeknights at 9:0
on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Rachel Maddow.
How are you, Rachel?
-I am, you know, inaugural-ish
-Does it feel real to you?
Does it feel real that thi
is the last full day
of the Trump presidency?
-I mean, what are the odds tha
this time tomorrow Trump's gone?
It just seems
absolutely impossible.
-I know.
-I don't know.
I mean, I know he's going to -
In my brain, I know it's true,
but in my guts, I feel lik
this is going to be
a persistent infection.
-I certainly agree with yo
on that.
But there is of course --
Because it's the last day,
we keep hearing the talk
of maybe 50 to 100 pardons
We're talking at around 4:00
in the afternoon.
They haven't happened yet.
Don't you think it will be
a fitting farewell present
from the President to you
if he does it, like,
five minutes before
your show starts tonight?
-[ Laughs ]
I am not egotistical enoug
to think that I have
a place in his mind.
But he does do a lot of stuf
at, like, 8:55.
-Yeah.
-And -- Eastern time.
Tight before the show starts
And, you know, everybody tha
I know in the news business --
everybody, people
on conservative networks
and liberal networks,
in between,
stray journalists, reporters -
everybody who has anything to do
with covering politics
has aged over these four years
the way presidents age
over four years.
You know how Obama
went in like a young man
and came out like Methuselah
I mean, they all do.
But it happened to the reporters
this time.
Everybody in the news business
we all have one major
new physical thing
wrong with us, at least.
-Yeah. And the President
looks exactly the same.
-[ Laughs ]
Yes, he absolutely does.
-To be fair, for the last
30 years, he's looked the same
So...
You -- I know you are someon
would likes
the ceremony of this office,
things like
the State of the Union.
Yet we have an inauguratio
that, for a lot of reasons
both be it safety,
COVID protocols,
a lot of it's going to be
virtual tomorrow.
Do you think
it will have the same effect
that a powerful inauguration
can have?
-It's an interesting question.
I've been thinking
a lot about it
because I'm going to be on air
all day covering it,
and I'm assuming
that it's going to be fine
But it is going to be different.
And part of what is meaningful
about ceremonies like this
and things
like State of the Union
and things like Election Night
is that there is a sort of
sameness or repetition
or tradition for it.
And even without
all the craziness
of, like, Trump leaving earl
and it has to be the usher
who lets the Bidens in
because the former First Lad
and former President
will have gone by then.
Even with all
of the Trump craziness,
just the COVID factor
and the way they have to do it
with so few people
is going to make it seem
not like other inaugurals.
I think it will
still feel, like, special
and important
and have a lot of gravitas
But the combination
of the Trump weirdness
and 20,000-plus troops
having to be there
because the transition of powe
was not peaceful this time
and the COVID stuff,
it is just going to be
once-in-a-lifetime.
I feel both good and bad
about that, I guess.
-There is obviously a lot that
the Biden/Harris administratio
is going to have to addres
right away,
but I'm wondering
what your thoughts are as far as
how the events of January 6t
are going to affect
the way President Biden governs,
especially early on.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
I mean, we'll see.
It's been a rollicking thing
to see since January 6th
that every day, there are ne
and very serious charges
being brought against people
who were part of the attac
on the Capitol,
including, you know,
conspiracy to commit an offens
against the United States,
which is the first time they'r
starting to bring charges
like that in terms of
there being an organized
command and control effort
to attack the government,
rather than just people
being charged with trespassing
or stolen property
and stuff like that.
So the charges
have been really serious.
But, you know, we'll see wha
the Biden Justice Department
does, for example,
and what the Biden-led FBI doe
on those things.
And it's just going to be --
I mean, it's a shocking thin
to have to deal with,
but, also, like,
how does it affect
everything else he wants to do
I keep thinking...
it's just kind of like
if you just got a new job,
you were just named
bank manager,
you're gonna be running
this branch of this bank
and you're super-excited,
and you've been building u
to this for a long time,
and you're really qualified,
and everybody's psyched
for you to take on this new job,
and you show up
for your first day
as the new manager of the bank
while the bank is being robbed
And it's like, "Well,
the first thing I have to do
as the new bank manager
is tie up the perpetrators
and call the police
and make sure everybody give
their witness statements."
I mean, Biden is taking over
in the middle of this, like,
incredible crime spree
that he has to deal with
on top of everything else.
-And then Biden has to --
The kind of guy he is,
is I feel like he then says,
like, "And, look, I'm not just
the president for the bank
and the people at the bank
I'm also the president
for the robbers.
I'm everybody's president.
-[ Laughs ] That's right.
"We need to understand why
they needed all of our money."
Yeah. The empathy
may be out of control.
-I actually want to ask
about that empathy in a second
We'll be right back with mor
from Rachel Maddow.